so i've been accumulating questions
on the leave your comments and questions
video
and i finally have enough to actually do
a video specifically about topics
in in religion because people have been
asking me that
so here are 10 shorts i'm gonna try to
keep them under
two minutes each where i answer
viewers and subscribers questions
comments
challenges complaints about religion
so this is an interesting and
provocative question by carl
george do you think faith is the most
dishonest position
someone could take and the simple answer
of course is no
um there are many more positions
that one could could take that are
explicitly dishonest like
lying cheating stealing you know being a
murderer for hire being a witness tamper
or any of those sort of things
um i think it's an interesting question
in part because it betrays
a kind of uh what should we call it
i hesitate to use the word sloppiness
but but rather
sort of a tar everything with the same
brush over
simplifying you know de-differentiating
kind of kind of thinking that is really
i know we all tend to fall into this but
it's no good when you
actually want to talk about anything
seriously
is faith a position well what does it
mean but to have a position
and what do people who actually talk
about faith
let alone people who for whom faith is
important who say that
they live out faith or you know it's an
integral part of their lives what do
they actually mean by that
if you just want to sort of engage in
polamics you don't have to worry about
that
if you actually want to know anything
about the phenomenon that you're you're
talking about then you actually have to
look at what religious believers
mean by it do they mean a set of
propositions to which
everybody is assumed to assent who has
faith um some people think of that that
way
other people think of it in terms of a
sort of lived commitment that that
becomes clearer and clearer over time
the more that one is actually engaging
in it some people think of it as a
relationship
is there anything inherently dishonest
about it i suppose if you've already
sort of prejudiced the question by by
staking out
you know all people who are religious
must be crazy or nuts or something like
that then you would think so but
if you're open-minded no
so this is an interesting question by
emmy star
do you personally believe that in high
schools if evolution is taught
shouldn't creationism be taught as well
and
my answer to that is a little bit
complex so first of all we we have to be
careful about what we mean by
taught do we mean in the sense of
presented as
the only thing that one can think in
this form of proselytizing
i mean if if evolution is being taught
in schools
in a scientific manner you know genuine
scientists are
fairly humble about their
epistemological commitments
but i think that a lot of high school
science teachers are not so they see
themselves as sort of crusaders for
enlightenment or things like that
um that said i don't i don't believe
that creationism and
and you know scientific theories about
evolution are really on the same
level i'd place creationism a bit lower
um now if we're talking about teaching
there's you know there's also the way of
teaching where you say
well look this is what you know people
who see things this way this is how they
see it this way
um and you know at the high school level
it's not like you're actually teaching
high level
evolutionary theory you're basically
just teaching a bit about it
unless you're in some really super
advanced high school in which case you
know all bets are off
so i think it's perfectly fine to say
here's what
most mainstream scientists think and
here's what you know a lot of americans
actually think is is probably the most
correct way here's what creationists
think you know if you're going to do
that though you probably should also
deal with other things like intelligent
design
which is in my view you know
a third alternative that doesn't reduce
to either one of them
and you if you really want to get
advanced with it you should probably
teach about the history of the notion of
evolution
and about how you know this would really
be to be scientific to show
how these things actually developed over
time show the evolution of evolution
but that doesn't get done and most of
the debates remain at this very low
level of creationism versus evolution
with a capital you know
letter for both of them which is
unfortunate
so rick seven jr has a number of
questions for me
about uh things having to do with the
bible and he asked what are your views
on biblical inerrancy
um if by biblical inerrancy you mean
what the people who tend to talk about
it quite a bit mean
i'm it's something i'm i'm rather
uninterested in
uh i'm i'm rather traditional
in this respect that i am a religious
believer
and i believe that god speaks to us
through the scriptures but i don't
believe
that it's any sort of uh
sort of like it just it's laid out for
you and you don't have to do work on
your part and
you know make the effort to try to
figure out what the context
was what the times were
and you know am i committed to every
single thing in the bible being
literally true
no and as a matter of fact um
there's plenty of great you know
christian authors in the past
who i look to as sort of you know uh
lighthouses or or
landmarks for me who didn't think that
that was particularly
central either who were more interested
in in the significance or the meaning of
it
and who could also see that you know not
everything is on the same plane
you know if for example you want to say
that that jesus
didn't say that we ought to um
turn the other cheek well that's a big
you know that's a big thing i
i think that things actually turn on
that if you want to say that
um you know in the bible people say that
pi is is 3 rather than 3.14 i don't care
nothing turns on that um and there's
there's everything in between
so i think that a lot of people get
really worked up about biblical
inerrancy because they want
the bible to be something that it's not
which is to be some sort of purely
imminent
everything is completely correct in it
sort of thing and then their critics
you know seize on that and and easily
point out
things that you know are inconsistencies
at least on the surface
another question by rick sevin jr what
are your views on the historicity of
jesus
so there's two ways we could we could
look at this
one is um asking did this guy even exist
was he remotely similar to to what the
canonical scriptures
record him as being and in this respect
we can ask about the historicity of
socrates the history
historicity of the buddha and there are
actually you know
quests for the historical you know
buddha out there just like there are
quests for the historical jesus
there are a few people who want to say
yeah this guy's totally made up no
person like that ever existed
they're so far out on the fringe that
they're not taken seriously even by
most of the fringe scholars so in that
respect yeah
the guy existed he walked around he
you know was most likely crucified no
reason to think that he wasn't
the question then is how much of the
canonical scriptures can we say
is actually reflective of what was going
on at the time
my views are pretty traditional in this
respect i don't see any reason to call
into
question whether jesus said the things
that are attributed to him
and i you know you can you can say well
you know
it's in this gospel but not in this
gospel well they're written for
different purposes you know when i would
teach
classes on the canonical and
non-canonical gospels
one of the things i would point out to
to my students is
look you know we don't know what he ate
on on thursday
march 17th in this year but that doesn't
mean that we don't have
some information about the guy they were
very selective in what they thought
ought to get passed on and that's you
know
there there are different theological
emphases from gospel to gospel
um i don't think that our our views
on um jesus is a historical figure are
particularly illuminated by
non-canonical documents they can lend a
little bit of light about mostly about
what these
christians over here were thinking or
these gnostics over here we're thinking
but for the most part we're stuck going
back to the canonical texts
all right another question by rick seven
jr to what extent does it really matter
if there are mistakes or things we know
are false in the bible
uh totally depends on what thing it is
in my view
because i don't think that that the
entire you know i i don't usually talk
about
the bible as one single document anyway
um the bible comes from tabiblia meaning
the books another word for that would be
library and these are texts that are
written
at different times and compiled together
and felt to
as a whole encompass the the word of god
um now you know you got to ask yourself
with respect to any one particular bit
of information
what would actually what would be the
case if this turns out to be false
um you know if
to use the example i used before if the
hebrews were
deceived about the nature of pi you know
the number
i don't care nobody cares only quibblers
care about that sort of thing
if on the other hand we were to find out
that jesus
actually didn't teach things like um
you should pray for your enemies you
should you know
be like the good samaritan and instead
he said you ought to
hear you know there would be the mistake
he actually said it's
every man for himself screw your
neighbor as much as you can
well that would be a huge you know
change right that would be
uh pretty revelatory but not even in any
sort of
non-canonical text do we find anything
remotely like that
um to what extent is it does it so to
what extent does it really matter if
there are mistakes or or things that we
know are wrong in the bible totally
depends on on
the thing depends on what would be
different
or what you know what upshot that would
have
and you gotta ask you know in a lot of
cases do we
you know if we think something is wrong
are we really sure about that are we
right about that or is that like based
on some sort of supposition some
conspiracy theory
some tendency to want to you know be in
the know by showing people up
that's what i find in a lot of these
discourses
here i'm going to give a totally
unsatisfying answer to
mark smith who asks me could you
elaborate on the terminology used in
trinitarian theology of essence
substance nature and person what does
each
term refer to and how do they differ
so in in in a two-minute video um
no i'm not going to be able to elaborate
on the terminology
used in trinitarian theology
upon which i can't even myself claim
to have a particularly great grasp not
only because
you know these these terms are used in
the different languages i'll get to that
moment
in in somewhat different ways but also
overlapping ways
but also because i actually do happen to
think that the trinity
is something that's particularly hard to
to grasp
for for us human beings so
um here's what i here's the only thing
that i'd have to say that's of
any merit when it comes to this um
if we look at authors who actually do
talk about this like like for example
saint anselm
we got words like essence substance
nature
and and person and
you know a greek term like usia uh
might be translated as essentia might be
translated as
you know in latin uh and somebody like
like anselm is really hip to that he
knows that that different
different languages use these words in
different ways and that different
authors use these in different ways
so the key is to look at what they what
they
claim this particular term has
rolled up into it and what sort of
upshot that has
um that's all i really have to
contribute on this i'm sorry
but i'm not a uh i'm not even a mediocre
theologian
so
so jacob hall has an interesting
question here in terms of religious
experience who
do you find most interesting
specifically what about
merton that is thomas merton so let me
answer that that that part
the last part first um i i've read
thomas merton
and i i i'm not really into him
or the kind of writers that that do the
same sort of thing
that he does i like his narrative parts
but i'm not particularly into his
discussions particularly about
mysticism because i tend to be
myself rather an anti-mystic i think
that god
is intelligible and that
although we may have a hard you know
time communicating what it is that that
we have experienced
or insights we've gained or the nature
of god that
um we were given reason and we were
given
you know the capacity to to uh
articulate things
for for a purpose and i think that a lot
of mysticism i'm not saying merton
actually falls in this but a lot of
mysticism is kind of a cop-out it's it's
like
cheap uh cheap theology
so i am very very interested in
religious experience i'm not
particularly
interested in secondary sources
sort of talking about religious
experience
although i do like william james quite a
bit i'm interested in actually
looking at what the primary sources have
to say
so you know if somebody had a religious
experience i want to read them
and read their account of it one thing i
will say though is i don't
i don't consider religious experience
and religious insight
and you know thinking about about the
matters of religion to be
totally dichotomous so thinking is an
experience you know what happens in
contemplation
is an experience just as much as
you know poking myself in the face is an
experience it's a different type of
experience
so rick seven junior has a question
specifically
on bart airman what do you think of the
work of bart d
airmens and some people that seem to
think that his books and findings
present a fatal blow to christianity
so first if his books
and findings were to present a fatal
blow to christianity that would be
an incredible surprise as a matter of
fact let's even take airmen out of the
picture
if somebody were to come up with some
sort of you know scholarship that showed
that it's
all a big hoax uh and actually
was real scholarship not just a lot of
sort of wishful thinking
and well it could be this way so i bet
you it is this way
hermeneutics of suspicion kind of stuff
that would indeed be
uh earth shaking nothing like that has
happened and nothing like that is likely
to
happen anytime soon uh and and you know
people have been trying to do this for
for quite some time um airman is an
interesting guy i actually have used his
work
in in teaching classes on the new
testament
and about you know canonical and
non-canonical
gospel literature and what i used was
his early work which was
actually i mean it had a particular
ideological edge to it
it was very clear that he didn't like
the orthodox and he was much more
sympathetic to the
to the non-orthodox or particularly to
the gnostics
um but it was still good scholarship it
was still stuff that you could say well
you know he's making an argument for
this and it's a plausible argument and i
think that
in his translations we can use those and
as you know
contextualizations provide us with some
some help so that's how he made his
bones
then he progressively went off into
further and further
you know fringe stuff with plenty of you
know backing from people like the jesus
seminar
um the thing that turned it for me that
turned me off on him was his
his stuff that he wrote about the gospel
of judas which was just
ludicrous um and and it was it became
very difficult for me to take him
seriously as a scholar after after that
you know i won't even say what i think
it is
so euro rumor has a question for me
about raising my kids
and and faith he says uh did you raise
them or are you currently raising them
as christians if so how did you
or or do you keep them open and free
thinkers
so it's interesting that you know the
the
background assumption should be that if
you're actually doing some sort of
religious education
or talking in any meaningful way about
faith and not just doing so in the kind
of religious studies well here's what
these people think here's what these
people think
that you're sort of indoctrinating them
or
or keeping them from being able to
develop openness
so first off whether even if we take the
religion off the table
if you don't teach something substantive
you actually preclude the possibility of
open-mindedness
because you need this is the way
people's minds develop you need to
actually grapple with things
and to be able to take a critical
position on them if all you have is some
vague
you know notions about it you can't even
really take a critical position on it
another way of putting this is in very
practical terms is
it's good to teach you know something so
that kids actually have something to
react and rebel against
now it is possible to teach in kind of a
brainwashing fashion and i've seen
people do that
and i've seen them do that in all sorts
of denominations and i've seen people do
that who are atheists as well
i personally think and this is part of
why i belong to the christian
intellectual tradition that
if you're actually using your mind the
way that god wants you to be using your
mind
you're not going to be brainwashed
yourself and you're not going to be
brainwashing anybody else you are in
fact going to be
inculcating in them a real love for the
truth that will lead them
to to you know try to figure out what
what's what
and um yeah that's probably enough about
that
so this is a bit of a follow-up question
from your rumor
and here's the it's off of the you know
raising kids
as christians if you did raise them as
christians and when they were six years
old they were asked whether they
believed in god would they have said yes
or no
if they were asked why they believe what
they believe what would they have said
what would you have wanted them to say
to both questions so that's a lot of
questions all rolled up in one
so first off let me say this
i think it's great if kids at six years
old believe in god
um i don't think that their conception
of god
is is hopefully it's nothing like what
they're going to have when they're 16
years old
and 26 years old it's going to be
something much more rudimentary
it's hard as hell for us adults even to
figure out
what exactly god is uh in part because
of the nature of the the very
object of that knowledge um we wouldn't
expect that a kid is going to have you
know
perfect knowledge about that either or
be able to provide
particularly cogent explanations
i would hope that my kids would be able
to say more than well my dad believes in
god so i believe in god
um but you know
i don't compel god so so
i don't decide whether whether uh what
sort of relationship god has with my
my kids and um
what would i have wanted them to say you
know
i would want them to say what they
actually think and i would want it to be
reflective of where they are
because i don't think that wherever they
are at six years old
is where they're going to be you know 10
years 20 years 30 years from from then
what all this reminds me of a lot is
that you know in the christian tradition
we have a
long long history of people saying man i
was totally wrong about god
my my conceptions of god at this this
time were dead dead off
read augustine's confessions you'll see
him say that over and over and over
again
very often our own imaginings about god
even if we say we believe in god tend to
be things that keep us from
you know truly knowing god and being
engaged with god